una nueva fosa común descubierta en
Ucrania Este martes se encontraron
decenas de cuerpos de civiles y
militares en la región liberada ciudad
del imán en el este de Ucrania
ya se encontraron 55 cuerpos pero el
trabajo continúa estos cuerpos son
civiles locales y nuestros Defensores
militares de las fuerzas armadas las
causas de las muertes serán determinadas
por peritos médicos judiciales
resultados preliminares causa de la
muerte lesiones por explosivos y
proyectiles lesiones por bala los
expertos tampoco descartan la
posibilidad de que las víctimas
sufrieran tortura
solo podremos decir con seguridad Una
vez que se haya realizado el peritaje
médico judicial Si una persona murió a
causa de la tortura de los ocupantes
en un contexto de bombardeos rusos
masivos en ciudades Ucrania en los
últimos días Rusia fue acusada una vez
más de cometer crímenes de guerra y de
apuntar a civiles pero a pesar de las
pruebas
Moscú sigue negando las acusaciones el
mes pasado se descubrió otra fosa común
donde los expertos se sumaron los
cuerpos de 436 personas según las
autoridades locales la mayoría parecía
haber tenido una muerte violenta las
fuerzas rusas han sido acusadas de
numerosas atrocidades en los territorios
que ocupan como también en busca donde
se descubrieron cadáveres de civiles
ejecutados cuando las fuerzas rusas se
retiraron a finales de marzo